The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: OK.
So, today is the first of a
pair of lectures taking us
from the Schrodinger picture
to the Heisenberg picture.
Or the wave function picture
to the matrix picture.
Now almost everyone who
does quantum mechanics
is rooted in the
Heisenberg picture.
We use the Heisenberg
picture because the structure
of the problem is immediately
evident when you write down
what you know.
And it's also mostly the way
you program your computers
to solve any problem.
So I'm going to get you to the
Heisenberg picture by dealing
with the two-level
problem, which is--
it should be called one of
the exactly solved problems,
except it's abstract as
opposed to harmonic oscillator,
particle in an infinite
box, rigid rotor.
It's a exactly-solved
problem, and it leads us to--
or guides us to--
the new approach.
I'm going to
approach this problem
the algebraic or
Schrodinger way.
And then I'm going to
describe it in a matrix way
and introduce the new
language and the new notation.
So I can say, at least at
the end of this lecture,
I'll be able to say
the word matrix element
and everybody will
know what it is,
and I'll stop talking
about integrals.
And one of the scary
things is, when
we go to the matrix
picture, we stop
looking at the wave function.
We never think about
the wave functions.
And so there are all sorts
of things like phases
that we have to make sure
we're not screwing up.
Because we're playing fast
and loose with symbols,
and sometimes they can bite
you if you don't know what
you're dealing with.
But mostly, we're going to
get rid of wave functions,
because we know all the
solutions to standard problems,
and we know a lot of integrals
involving those solutions
to standard problems.
And so basically, all
we need is an index
saying this wave function or
this state, this integral,
and you have--
and then you can
write down everything
you need in matrix
notation, and then you
can tell your friendly computer,
OK, solve the problem for me.
OK.
So once I give you
the matrix picture,
then I will talk about how
you find the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of the
matrix picture using
a unitary transformation.
And then I'll generalize
from the two-level problem,
which is exactly soluble.
You don't need a computer
for it, but it's convenient--
because you don't have
to write anything down--
to N levels where
N can be infinite.
And the N-level problem
is in principle difficult
because even a computer can't
diagonalize an infinite matrix.
And all of your basis sets,
all of your standard problems
involve an infinite
number of functions.
And so I've introduced
a notation and a concept
of solving a matrix equation,
but you can't do it unless you,
say, let's make
an approximation,
and it's called nondegenerate
perturbation theory.
And this is the
tool for learning
almost everything
you want to know
about complicated problems.
And it's not
complicated to apply
nondegenerate
perturbation theory.
It's just ugly.
But it's really
valuable because you
don't have to
remember how to solve
a particular complicated
differential equation,
you just write
down what you know
and you do some simple
stuff, and bang, you've
got a solution to the problem.
And this is really what
I want you to come away
from this course with--
the concept that anything that
requires quantum mechanics
you can solve using some
form of perturbation theory.
So hold onto your seats.
So the Schrodinger picture
is differential equations.
And they're often coupled
differential equations.
And you don't want
to go there, usually.
And we're going to replace
that with linear algebra.
Now many of you have not had
a course in linear algebra.
And so that should make
you say, can I do this?
And the answer is,
yeah, you can do this
because the linear
algebra you are going
to need in this course
is based on one concept,
and that is that the solution
of coupled linear homogeneous
equations involves diagonalizing
or solving a determinant.
And when you solve this
determinant of the equation,
it's equivalent to
diagonalizing a matrix.
And that's the language we're
going to be using all the time.
And so the only thing
I'm not going to do
is prove this fundamental
theorem of linear algebra,
but the notation is easy to use
and the tricks are very simple.
So, we have with
exactly-solved problems
complete sets of the energy
levels of the wave functions.
And we know a lot of integrals.
Psi i operator psi j d tau.
We know these not
by evaluating them,
but because the functions are so
simple that we can write these
as simply a function of the
initial and final quantum
numbers.
And so all of a
sudden, we forget
about the wave functions,
because all the work
has been done for us.
We could do it too, but why?
So we start with the
two-level problem.
And the two-level
problem says we have
two states, psi 1 and psi 2.
Still in the
Schrodinger picture.
And this has an energy which
we could we could call E1,
and that would be H11,
the diagonal integral
of the Hamiltonian between the
1 function and the 1 function,
and this is E2.
Now these two states
have an interaction.
They're connected by
an interaction term
which causes them to repel
each other equal and opposite
amounts.
And so this is H12.
Again, an integral, which you
usually don't have to evaluate,
because it's basically
done for you.
And then we get E
plus and E minus,
and the corresponding
eigenfunction.
So this is the
two-level problem,
and it's expressed in
terms of three parameters--
H11, H22, and H12.
And we get the two energy levels
and the two eigenfunctions.
And we know how to solve this
problem in the Schrodinger
picture, and I'll do that first.
And so, H11 is just this
integral, psi 1 star H.
And we put a hat on H
for the time being--
1 d tau.
And H22 is a different integral
of psi 2 star H psi 2 d tau.
And H12 is psi 1
star H psi 2 tau.
And we know that the Hamiltonian
operator is Hermitian,
and so we can write
also that this is
psi 2 star H star psi I d tau.
Anyway, we call this thing V.
And there's some subtleties.
If the integral between these
two things is imaginary,
then the 1-2 and 2-1
integrals have opposite signs.
Because the Hamiltonian
is Hermitian.
But let's just think of
this as just one number.
So we have E1, E2, and delta.
So the two-level problem
is going to let us find
the eigenfunctions--
the plus and minus
eigenfunctions.
C plus 1.
So we have eigenfunctions
corresponding to-- which
are eigenfunctions belonging to
the eigenvalues, E plus and E
minus.
And there are a linear
combination of the two states.
Now, it's a two-level problem.
This is a state space that
contains only two states.
It's not an approximation.
And so completeness says
we can write any function
we want as a linear combination
of the functions and the basis
set.
And so our job is going to
be to find these coefficients
and also to find the
energy eigenvalues.
OK.
So let's start to do some work.
We know this thing.
And let's start some--
and we know that
H psi plus-minus
has to be equal to the
eigenenergies psi plus-minus.
Now, in order to get
something useful out of this,
we left multiply by psi 1.
OK.
And when you left
multiply by psi 1-- well,
let's just write it out.
We're going to get
psi 1 HC 1 plus.
So let's just write this out.
We have H11 C1 plus-minus.
Because this is C
plus-minus, and we
have the integral of psi 1
with itself or the Hamiltonian
is H11.
And then we get another term.
I'm doing this
differently from my notes,
so the other term is C
plus-minus psi 2 V. OK.
So plugging in what I have over
here and knowing that H11--
we know that V is psi 1 H psi
2, and so this is what we get.
We do the same thing, and we
have the same left-hand side,
but we can also now
express this as that H--
that psi plus-minus
is an eigenfunction.
And so we have the
same left-hand side,
but on the right-hand
side, we now
get integral psi 1 star
H psi plus-minus d tau.
But that's equal to psi star E
plus-minus C1 plus-minus psi 1
plus C2 plus-minus psi 2 d tau.
OK.
And so now we're talking about
orthonormality of the wave
function, and because we don't
have any operators in here,
then this thing becomes simply
E plus-minus times C1 plus-minus
plus 0 C2 plus-minus.
There should be a 1 here.
OK.
Because psi 1, psi
2, that's orthogonal.
So now we have an equation
that's quite useful.
So we're going to combine
these two equations,
and we get C1 plus
H11 plus C2 plus--
I'm sorry, this is
plus-minus, plus-minus.
V is equal to E
plus-minus C1 plus-minus.
Now we need another equation.
And so we do the same thing and
we left multiply by psi 2 star
and integrate.
And we get another
equation, and that
is C1 plus-minus the plus
C2 plus-minus H22 minus E
plus-minus is equal to 0.
So we combine the two equations
that we have derived, solving--
because both equations can be
solved for C1 plus-minus or C2
plus-minus.
So we equate the C1
plus-minus over C2 plus-minus
from the two equations.
And we get this wonderful
result, V over H11 minus E
plus-minus is equal to H22
minus E plus-minus over V.
Now you're not going
to ever do this.
So yes, you can attempt
to reconstruct this
from what I read on the board
or what's in your notes,
but the important point is that
we're just using what we know.
We say we have
eigenfunctions, and we
want to find something about
the coefficients of the basis
functions in each of
the eigenfunctions.
And we want to find
the eigenvalues,
and we get this equation.
So, this is easy.
We relate this to--
we just multiply
through and we get V2,
V squared is equal to H11
minus E plus-minus times H22
minus E plus-minus.
Or we solve, and we know that
E plus-minus is equal-- this
is a quadratic equation.
A quadratic and E plus-minus,
and so we have this result,
H11 plus H22 plus or
minus this H11 squared--
H11 plus H22 squared minus 4
H11 H22 minus V squared over 2.
This is just a
quadratic equation.
So we have the eigenenergies
expressed in terms
of the quantities we know.
We simplify the notation.
E bar is H11 plus H22 over 2.
And delta is H11
minus H22 over 2.
So when we do that, we
simplify the algebra
and we end up discovering that
the eigenvalue equation is
E plus-minus is equal to E bar
plus or minus delta squared
plus V squared square root.
That's a simple result. This is
something you should remember.
So if you have a
two-level problem,
the energy eigenvalues are the
average energy plus or minus
this quantity.
This is an exact solution
for a two-level problem.
For all two-level problems.
OK.
And we even simplify
the notation more.
We call X delta
squared plus V squared.
And so this becomes E
bar plus-minus X squared.
Pretty compact.
Now, the reason for
simplifying the notation
is that we're going
to derive the values
for the eigenfunctions, and
they involve a lot of symbols.
And we want to make this
as compact as possible,
and so we'll do that.
OK.
So when we started
out, it looked
like we were going to
solve for these quantities,
but we took a detour and solved
for the eigenenergies first.
And this is one of the things
that happens in linear algebra.
You get something
you can get easily--
quickly before you get the
other stuff that you want.
OK, but the second
part of the job
is to find these
mixing coefficients.
And so one thing
you do is you say,
well, we insist that the
wave functions be orthog--
normalized.
After that a lot
of algebra ensues.
And I'm not going to even
attempt to work through it.
You may want to work through
it, but what I recommend doing
is looking at the
solution and then
checking to see
whether it does things
that you expect it has to do.
Because one of the things
that kind of inspection
leads you to is factors of
two errors and sign errors.
OK.
But, C plus-minus--
C1 plus-minus
is equal to 1/2
times 1 plus or minus
delta over the square root
of X. Two square roots.
Whoops.
OK, no square root
in here because we
get square root there.
OK and C2 plus-minus
is 1/2 1 minus or plus
delta square root,
x square root.
OK?
So these two things are
kind of simple-looking,
but there's an awful
lot of compression
and select and
clever manipulation
in order to get this.
But the important
thing to notice
is that we have the
energy difference divided
by this thing, this
delta squared plus V
squared that expresses
the importance
of the two-level interaction.
And these two things
enter with opposite signs.
OK.
And so one of the checks
that's really easy to do
is let's let V go to 0, and
let's let V go to infinity.
OK, remember, our Hamiltonian--
the two-level problem--
I can't write it
as a matrix yet,
so remember that we
had E1, E2, and V.
And this was the higher energy,
this was the lower energy,
and so delta is E1 minus E2--
I better not write that.
OK.
So we normally write E1 over E2,
and we have this V interaction
between them.
OK.
And so if the interaction
integral between the two
functions is 0, then E1
is the higher energy,
and it corresponds to--
it should correspond
to psi 1 alone.
Well, so the higher energy we're
taking the plus combinations
here, and if V is equal to 0,
then this is delta over delta.
And this is either 2 or 0.
And when it's the higher--
the upper sine, it's
2 divided by 2 or 1,
exactly what you expect.
And this one is 1 minus 1.
So these two are
behaving, right?
And the V to 0 rate.
Now, in the V going to
infinity, then this is infinite.
So that just means that
this term goes away, right?
And so we have C1 plus and minus
is equal to square root of 2--
1 over the square root of 2.
And same here.
So what we get is what
we call 50/50 mixing.
OK, so this also works.
So I don't say that this can--
this confirms that I have not
made an algebraic mistake,
I haven't, but it's a good test
because it's really easy to do.
And if you're not
getting what you expect,
you know you've either
blown a sign or a factor
or two, which are the two things
that you fear most in a wave
function free approach.
Because you've got nothing to
do except check your algebra,
and usually, you made the
mistake because it was subtle,
and you'll make it again
when you're checking it.
So these kinds of checks
are really valuable.
OK.
So once you know that this
is likely to be correct,
then you do some
other things, and you
check the wave functions you've
derived with your C plus-minus
1 and C plus-minus two are
both normalized and orthogonal.
And that the energy you get is
such that psi plus is E plus.
And you know what E plus was.
And so you just go
in and you calculate
what the energy should be
giving using the values for PSI
plus-minus And so we plug those
into the original equations.
And you can also, again,
show that psi plus-minus
a star H psi plus-minus
is equal to 0
because the eigenfunctions
are orthogonal.
We already did that, but we
plugged it into an equation
here, and we got
it a second time.
So in the lecture notes, there
is a lengthy algebraic proof
or demonstration
that E plus-minus
is equal to plus or
minus square of x,
which are already
derived, but then I
just did it the long way.
OK .
So this is it--
we are about to move from
the Schrodinger picture
to the matrix picture.
So the trick now is to
go to linear algebra,
go to the matrix
picture and learn
how to just write the equations
and what the language is
and show that it works.
So suppose you have two
square matrices, A and B,
they're n by n squared
matrices, you know the rules
for matrix multiplication?
So if you wanted, the mn
element of this product or two
matrices, you would
go, n equals--
i equals 1.
Let's use the same notation.
j equals 1 to n of Am--
because I want the mn--
j Bjn.
And so when you multiply
two square matrices,
you get back a square matrix.
And this picture
is not a bad one.
So you can say, all right.
So if you need a little
q to remind yourself,
you take this row and
multiply term by term
and add the results--
this row in that column,
and you get a number here.
And you just repeat that,
and it's really easy
to tell your
computer to do this,
and it's rather tedious
to do it yourself
if it's more than a
two-by-two matrix.
OK.
So what about this thing C?
Well, C is a N
row column matrix.
So it's N rows, 1 column.
It looks like this--
C1, C2, Cn.
And so if you want to multiply
a square matrix by a vector,
we know the rules too, OK?
And again, this picture
is a useful one.
So let's just draw
something like this.
We do this and this,
and that gives you
one element in the column.
OK.
Now, the last thing that
I want to remind you of--
I better use this board.
If we have a two-state problem,
then the vector c1 is 1, 0;
the vector c2--
this should be a lower
case c, because we
tend to use lowercase letters
for vectors and uppercase
letters for matrices.
And so if we do c1 dagger
c2, or c1 dagger c1.
Now this dagger means conjugate
transpose, except, well,
there isn't anything to do
except convert a matrix--
a vector into-- so that
becomes a row and this
becomes a column.
And so a row times the
column gives a number.
And that number is going
to be-- well, let's do it.
We have 1, 0; 0, 1.
1 times 0 is 0, 0 times
1 is 0, and so this is 0.
Well that's orthogonality.
This, we have 1 times 1 is 1.
0 times 0 is 0.
So it's 1 plus 0.
Right.
OK, all right.
OK.
So the Schrodinger equation
becomes in matrix language--
and now, one notation is--
I'm going to stop using
the double underline.
That means boldface.
And we don't use hats anymore.
Or at least if we were
really consistent,
when we go away from
the Schrodinger picture,
we don't put hats on operators,
we make them boldface letters.
OK.
Now, the thing is we're so
comfortable in matrix land,
that we don't use either.
OK.
But remember, we're talking
about different things.
So the Schrodinger
equation looks like this.
And so we have a matrix,
delta v, v delta times 1, 0.
And that's delta, v; or delta
times 1, 0 plus v times 0, 1.
Isn't that interesting?
Remember, the Hamiltonian
or any operator operating
on a function gives rise
to a linear combination
of the functions
and the basis set.
And so here's one of the
functions, here's the other.
OK.
Nothing very mysterious
has happened here.
So this very equation is
going to be HC is equal to EC.
OK, so how do we approach this?
Well I have to
introduce a new symbol,
and that's going to be this
symbol T. It's a matrix.
It's a unitary matrix.
And we want it to have
a special properties.
Those special properties
will be shown here.
OK, so first of all,
we have this matrix--
T11, T--
AUDIENCE: Your Hamiltonian
matrix is incorrect.
So I think you mean to
say E bar plus-minus?
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: I think the diagonal
elements of the Hamiltonian
matrix should be--
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah, OK.
If we wanted the
eigenvalues, OK?
This is--
AUDIENCE: So the infinite
matrix in this case should be--
the diagonal elements
should be E1 and E2.
So I think you meant
E bar plus delta,
and then E bar minus delta.
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah.
OK.
There is something in
the notes and something
in my notes which--
we can always write
the Hamiltonian
as E bar 0, 0, E bar plus
delta v v minus delta.
We can always take out
this constant term.
And this is the thing
we're always working on.
And so rather than--
and so we could
call this H prime.
Or we can simply say, oh,
we have these two things--
this always gets added
in, and it's not affected.
If we take this
diagonal constant matrix
and apply a transformation to
it, a unitary transformation,
you get that matrix again,
you get-- it's nothing.
OK, so we wanted to
describe some special matrix
where the transpose
of that matrix
is equal to the
inverse of that matrix.
Now-- yes?
AUDIENCE: So shouldn't
there be a minus on there?
On the prior equation?
For the bottom right entry.
The primary delta and the--
first line.
First line.
ROBERT FIELD: This
is delta minus the--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But up there, you
just had delta delta.
ROBERT FIELD: Yep.
Thank you.
OK.
Now, when you have
a matrix, you really
like to have T minus 1T is
equal to the unit matrix.
Getting the inverse of a
matrix in a general problem
is really awful.
But for a unitary matrices,
all you do to get the inverse
is to take--
you flip it on the diagonal.
Now strictly, the conjugate
transpose of a unitary matrix
is the inverse.
But often we have real matrices.
But the important thing is
always this flipping along--
flipping the matrix
on the diagonal.
And that gives you the
inverse unless there
is stuff here that is complex.
OK.
So this conjugate transpose,
it would look like--
OK?
OK.
Now, what we want to do
is derive the matrix form
of the Schrodinger
equation using
this unitary transformation.
So we start out again
with HC is equal to EC.
And now, we insert TT dagger.
And this is one of the
things where you screw up.
Whether you insert TT
dagger or T dagger T,
because they're both 1.
And if you use the wrong
one, all of your phases,
everything is wrong.
But it's still correct,
the equations are correct,
but the things you've memorized
are no longer correct.
OK, so we're going
to insert this unit
matrix between H and C.
And of course, we have to--
we would have to insert
this on the other side.
T T dagger C and
E. But that's one.
OK, so we don't do anything
on the left-hand side.
And now we left
multiply by T dagger.
OK.
And we call this H twiddle,
and we call this C twiddle.
So we have H twiddle, C
twiddle is equal to EC twiddle.
Now we're cooking.
OK, because we construct
this unitary matrix
to cause this Hamiltonian,
the transformed Hamiltonian
to be in diagonal form.
So we say that H twiddle,
which is T dagger T,
is equal to E plus, E minus,
0, 0 for the 2 by 2 problem.
OK, that leads to
some requirements.
What are the elements
of the T matrix?
But the important thing is
we say that T diagonalizes H.
So this magic matrix gives
you the energy eigenvalues.
But we also have T dagger
C is equal to C twiddle.
And so this gives you
the linear combination
of the column vectors that
correspond to the eigenvector.
So what is it?
We have here T dagger, which
is TT, T12 T, T21 T, T22 T
times C. And that's supposed
to be equal to C twiddle or C1
twiddle, C2 twiddle.
So we put everything together
and we discover that OK,
when we multiply
this by that, we get
the element that goes up here.
And so the element on top is
C1 T11 dagger plus C2 T12--
I'm using T's and
daggers independently,
and we do the same thing here.
So we have a column
vector, and it's
composed of the original state.
And so anyway, when
we do everything,
we discover that
using the solution
to the two-level problem
from the Schrodinger picture,
we know everything.
So H twiddle, C twiddle plus
is H plus C twiddle plus.
And that's just E plus 1, 0.
And H twiddle C twiddle
minus is E minus times 0, 1.
OK.
This is all very confusing
because the notation
is unfamiliar.
But the important thing
is that everything
you can do in the
Schrodinger picture you
can do in this matrix picture.
And you can find these
elements of this T matrix,
and it turns out that what you--
the matrix that diagonalizes the
Hamiltonian, the columns of T
dagger are the eigenvectors.
So you find this
matrix, it diagonalizes
H. The computer tells
you the eigenenergies,
and it also tells you
T dagger or T plus--
TT.
And so with that,
you know how to write
in the original basis set
what the eigenbasis is
for each eigenvalue.
And so the next step, which
will happen in the next lecture,
is the general unitary
transformation for two-level.
Now, you expect
that there is going
to be a general solution
for the two-level problem,
because the two-level problem
in the Schrodinger picture
led to a quadratic equation.
And that had an
analytical solution.
And so there is going to be
a general and exact solution
the two-level problem.
And this unitary
transformation is
going to be written in terms
of cosine theta sine theta
minus sine theta cosine theta.
This is a matrix
which is unitary,
and it, when applied
to your basis set,
conserves normalization
and orthogonality.
And so the trick is
to be able to find
the theta that causes the
Hamiltonian in question
to be diagonalized.
And the algebra for that will
happen in the next lecture.
OK.
Remember, you're not
going to do this ever.
You're going to use the idea
of this unitary transformation,
and you're going to
use that to get--
to diagonalize the matrix.
And this will lead
to some formulas
which you're going
to like, because you
can forget sines and cosines.
Everything is going
to be expressed
in terms of things like this--
V over delta.
So we have matrix element--
off diagonal matrix element
over the energy difference.
And that's the basic form of
nondegenerate perturbation
theory, which is applied
not just in 2-by-2 problems,
but to all problems.
And so you want to
remember this lecture as,
this is how we kill
the two-level problem.
Then we can discover
what we did and apply it
to a general problem
where it's not
a two-level problem
anymore, it's
an infinite number of levels.
And when certain
approximations are met,
it applies, and it gives you
the most accurate energy levels
and wave functions
you could want.
And you know how accurate
they are going to be.
And this is liberating,
because now, you
can take a not
exactly-solved problem
and you can solve
it approximately.
And you can use the
solution to determine, OK,
there's going to be some
function of the quantum numbers
which describes
the energy levels.
Well what is that function?
And what are the coefficients
in that function?
And how do they
relate to the things
you know from the Hamiltonian?
So it's incredibly powerful.
And once you're
given the formulas
for nondegenerate
perturbation theory,
you can solve practically any
problem in quantum mechanics.
Not just numerically,
but with insight.
It tells you, if we make
observations of some system,
we determine a set of energy
levels, which is called
the spectrum of that operator.
And the spectrum of the
operator is an explicit function
of the physical constants--
the unique interactions
between states.
And so you will then know
how the experimental data
determines the mechanism
of all the interactions,
and you can calculate
the wave function.
You can't observe
the wave function,
but you can discover its
traces in the energy levels.
And then you can reproduce
the energy levels,
and if you have the energy
levels-- the eigenstates,
you can also describe
any dynamics using
the same formulas in here.
So this is an
incredible enablement.
And you don't have to
look at my derivations.
I'm not proud of
the derivations,
I'm proud of the results.
And if you can handle
these results that
come from perturbation
theory as well as you've
done so far in
the course, you're
going to be at the
research level very soon.
OK, see you on Friday.